as our calendars approach 2020 the
reigning king of the streaming Wars
Netflix is getting rid of a number of
movies to make room for everything
that's coming to the site at the start
of the new year these are the movies you
have to watch before they leave Netflix
in January 2020 even in a brand new
decade Greece is still the word but it
won't retain that status on Netflix
after January 31st 2020 the 1978 film a
silver screen adaptation of the 1971
musical of the same name features olivia
newton-john and John Travolta as a pair
of click crossed highschool sweethearts
who navigate their whirlwind romance the
status quo at Rydell High and greaser
culture with plenty of song and dance if
you somehow yet to see Greece and are
unfamiliar with the rock and roll in
Danny Zuko and his sweet turn sassy
Australian squeeze sandy Olsen now's the
perfect time to catch the film from the
comfort of your couch and if you're like
the vast majority of the people in the
world and simply can't resist the charms
of the film's characters and
infectiously cheery soundtrack don't
miss out on streaming Greece for the
thousandth time on Netflix before the
month is up taking a hard left turn away
from the feel-good fun of Greece we
arrived at American Psycho director Mary
herons half black comedy half
psychological horror that adapts Bret
Easton Ellis's novel of the same name
into a story that simmers below the
surface before it's splatters all over
the place released in April 2002 much
critical acclaim
American Psycho centers on the
well-to-do detail-oriented investment
banker Patrick Bateman whose obsessions
insecurities and penchant for extreme
violence billed to bursting pretty yeah
I mean I get some a pretty sick guy this
one's not for the faint of heart or
anyone with the fear of chainsaws but
for those wanting a terrifying flick to
get sucked into you have until January
31st 2020 to watch American Psycho on
Netflix before she was a teen girl who
fell in love with a vampire
prior to her string of acclaimed indie
flix and years ahead of her stint as one
of Charlie's Angels Kristen Stewart
splashed onto the Hollywood scene with
her breakout film role in 2002's panic
room and director David Fincher's
thriller Stewart stars as Sara Altman
the daughter of Jodie Foster's character
Meg Altman the mother-daughter pair
move into a new hall a multi-story
brownstone nestled in New York City's
Upper West Side neighborhood following
makes recent divorce you may predict
where the plot is headed that Megan
Sarah's new home is haunted by entities
hungry for revenge but panic room plays
out differently
Megan Sarah discovered that the previous
owner of the home built a panic room a
fortified hiding place to protect
occupants in the event of a home
invasion natural disaster or other
threat of the same ilk but that's not
all that's inside the home
trouble comes knocking on the Altman's
door the very first night they move in
the grandson of the previous owner jr.
along with his two accomplices Burnham
and Raul break into the home in search
of three million dollars locked in a
floor safe inside the panic room
the Altman's engaged on a life-or-death
game of cat-and-mouse with the trio of
home invaders who are determined to
seize the money by whatever means
necessary panic room is available to
stream on Netflix until January 31st
2020 2019 saw the theatrical launch of
Zombieland double tap the long-awaited
sequel to 2009's beloved zombie comedy
zombie land the flick directed by
returning Helmer ruben fleischer
catapulted the property back into
pop-culture consciousness and had people
scrambling to re-watch the original
zombie land whether you saw the sequel
in cinemas or decided to skip it the og
flick holds up better than Twinkies do
in a zombie apocalypse
so in January 2020 sit down with mad
person disease survivors Tallahassee
Columbus Wichita and Little Rock and
watch as they fight off hordes of
zombies share their rules for avoiding
death and form their dysfunctional yet
lovable makeshift family zombie land
leaves Netflix on January 31st 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]